hello belief nation is Evan my one word
is believed and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves and my
sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you can
change the planet so I started this
series on the path to 1 million
subscribers to document my journey on
the path to getting a million YouTube
subscribers to my channel and hopefully
giving you guys some lessons and
education and tips and tools and
training along the way it's been a
little bit since my last video we did it
at the end of May at that time I had
what six hundred and ninety eight
thousand subscribers right now I'm
sitting at around seven hundred and
seventy five thousand subscribers depend
on when this video goes live and this
one is a little bit different so in the
past I've compared myself to other
youtubers and said here's what these
guys need to be doing better to rise up
and grow and why I've been able to do
beat people even though I consider them
to have potential a lot more talent am i
doing a lot of different areas just by
understanding kind of YouTube's
algorithm today I wanted something
different today I want to talk about
three strategies that are really popular
that I recently stopped doing stopped
going after and focusing on the one
that's really really really making a
huge difference and hopefully so that
you guys can learn as well so strategy
number one is to get celebrity
endorsements if somebody big recommends
your channel it's going to grow you're
going to get a lot of traction you're
going to get a lot of you know people
subscribing to your channel and I've had
the good fortune of having a lot of
people share the videos that we've done
on them and so I looked at three that we
had recently one Tyrese Gibson the actor
shared the top 10 we did on his
Instagram in his link in his bio which
was awesome since there's a lot of
people are way too 50 cent here at the
top 10 we did on him too his audience
and he put it on Twitter and on his blog
and on his Facebook and three Floyd
Mayweather also shared the top 10 we did
on him and I always want to make content
that I think people will want to share
we didn't approach any of these people
to hey can you please share this but
it's also not surprising for me we want
to create content that if they saw it
they would want to share it and so I
thought to look at the analytics and
dive deep and see what was the impact of
them sharing that video so
first up is Tyrese and again Tyrese
shared on Instagram bio is the link so
on that first day you can see there's
this massive spike it led to what five
thousand views almost six thousand views
there on that first day and then if you
look at the subscriptions driven it only
led to five new subscribers it's like
almost six thousand views from his
Instagram bio and only five people
subscribed total from that like maybe
some people found us other ways to I
don't even know if all five were
necessary from him but if you look at
the long tail look at how it keeps going
out over time you'll see that you know
the weeding get the traffic ongoing but
we continue to get new subscribers and
so the impact of him sharing it led to a
ton of views but didn't lead to people
subscribing to my channel and so I
thought that's not fantastic how about a
continue that experiment and let's look
at who we did next 50 cent so 50 cent
again shared it on his blog on his
Facebook I was Twitter and it didn't
even better in the first day right we
had 20,000 views on the first day and
the subscribers were a little bit better
right almost 40 subscribers on the first
day that it came out and so that's great
amazing traffic thank you 50 cent I
appreciate the love but again it only
led to 40 subscribers not even from
20,000 people who saw the video it only
lets the 40 subscribers I never thought
I'd do one more and that was Floyd
Mayweather and he shared his I forget
where he shared his on one of his social
networks and he caught a little bit
linked so the video was released and it
had this spike and then it sort of
dropping down and then his massive spike
up in views because he caught and he
showed on his platform and it led to
what twenty two and a half thousand
views something like that in the video
and on that same day we had just over
twenty subscribers joined the channel so
from again this huge number of people
who are viewing the video to a tiny tiny
tiny percent you people like you
subscribe and so if you get celebrity
endorsements you get some big person
talking about you it can lead to a large
number of people
watching your videos but it doesn't lead
to a lot of people subscribing to the
videos and so it's still a decent
strategy the problem is you only have a
little amount of time right you only
have so many hours in a day every day
that if you are actively spending your
time trying to get celebrity
endorsements then you might be able to
use that time doing something else oh to
have higher leverage now me being able
to say that 50-cent share this video and
Flo Mayweather share this video and
Tyrese Gibson and other people share
their videos that helps me if I'm doing
an interview or if I'm trying to make a
connection I can use their name to say
hey these people appreciate my work that
helps me but just in terms of getting
subscribers it's not the best strategy
so the second thing I want to talk about
is the value of collaborations it's one
of the most recommended piece of advice
that you get and you hear from youtubers
on how to grow your YouTube channel and
I thought that I talked about as well in
previous videos about how to grow a
YouTube channel make collaborations and
it has benefited me in my channel and I
want to look at well how much has it
benefited me in terms of getting
subscribers to the channel and so I had
the good fortune to go to an event not
that long ago called climber con it was
in California and it was a bunch of
different youtubers who all had sizable
channels and out of that came six
seventy different collaborations me on
their channels them on my channels doing
different things together but how much
it helped me actually grow my channel so
the biggest one that I did was with the
guys from Chrismukkah main name is
Charlie awesome dude we had a lot of fun
went to an escape room together and ate
meals together a lot of fun meeting him
I'm a huge fan of his channel by the way
to learn about charisma that's the place
to go to recommend starting with the
Kevin Hart video if you did that was
just awesome and so he made a video on
me about how to network as an introvert
because I'm introverted and he was
impressed at how I was networking and so
he wanted to make a video on me and so
the video talks about me and networking
and at the end also has this really
awesome shadow to my channel with the
link in the video right on the end card
there's a link to my video which is
awesome it's not just click in the
description and hoping people go there
is the
link right there so that video when it
first came out first day did about
40,000 views just under 37 38 thousand
views something around there and then if
I go to my analytics to look at
subscribers you'll see that I had a big
spike right I had a big spike up to
about 20 100 subscribers something like
that which is way above what I was
getting before you know my average was
maybe 1100 you know Charlie gave me a
thousand new subscribers because of that
video on the first day Thank You charlie
appreciate it man and well that's great
and it came from you know 30 what 40,000
people see it and a thousand new people
subscribe that's awesome overall you
know a hundred thousand of people have
watched that video will get a certain
percentage of that overall which is
great but again what you have to look at
is the time and effort that goes into
making these collaborations the time to
build that relationship time for me to
go to comic-con the time to connect and
talk and share ideas and all of that
work it's a lot of work and so I like
doing it because it's fun I love
supporting other entrepreneurs other
youtubers and I do a lot of videos and
collaborations on tiny channels channels
of the hundred subscribers I just like
it but as a strategy it's not the most
effective one because while it did add a
thousand new subscribers on that day for
me it's great I was already getting 1100
subscribers a day and this is a channel
that has almost a million subscribers so
it's not I can say well if you did it
with somebody who had 10 million
subscribers you get a huge boost
I would but there are that many people
with tens out ten million subscribers
right so just weighing the cost benefits
now if you are just getting started and
you have a hundred subscribers and you
get a deal with someone who has a
million subscribers and that leads to a
thousand new subscribers to your channel
overnight that's a huge deal right if
you have a thousand to start with you
just doubled your channel that's a big
deal
but unless you're shooting way above
your weight class and you can provide
some kind of insane value I'm really
starting to doubt the value of the
collaborations just in terms of
generating subscriber
again having friends having a connection
having a network being able to say that
I work with this person this person this
person I can all help in the grand
scheme of things but if your only goal
is try to get subscribers I don't think
collaborations is the best way to go the
third thing I want to talk about is off
platform marketing a lot of times again
a lot of best practice is when if you
get a video out you have to share it off
platform you got to share it on your
Twitter and share it on your Facebook
and put it in your newsletter and share
it to everybody that you know right
share it on platform and what the data
has shown me at least to these examples
is off platform performed way way way
way WAY worse than in platform even just
comparing the celebrities that I had
versus the crews motorman video if you
look at the 50 cent one as an example
right 50 cent or the members here 50
cent gave me 20,000 views in the first
day krismo command had 40,000 views 50
cent gave me 20 subscribers so 20,000
views 20 subscribers Kristin one command
40,000 views a thousand subscribers huge
difference so if you're going to be
marketing a much rather market in
platform within the YouTube platform
than going elsewhere and I guess it
makes sense the people who are addicted
to Twitter not all of them are super
addicted YouTube not all of them will go
and want to even go to youtube and if
they do they don't they're not in the
habit of subscribing the channels and
watching video you want the people who
are already in platform and so that made
a huge difference for me and I'm still
going to post my videos up on Twitter
and I'm still going to post on Facebook
and I'm still going to select some
within my newsletter but to bank on that
as a marketing strategy is not really
smart in my opinion it does not lead to
you getting tons of new subscribers and
so what's the thing that works so we've
just discounted celebrity doors friends
who just discounted collaborations they
were just this kind of off platform
marketing strategy what's the thing that
works the thing that works is things
I've talked about including much every
single video in this series is creating
consistent content I had a meeting last
night with a up-and-coming youtuber and
he's making three videos
week he's trying to get it higher I says
if you get to a video a day you're going
to start crushing it a lot more if you
can do one quality video per day that
should be your new baseline minimum
standard one per day is the minimum you
want to get to two a day ideally but
right now one day is the minimum if you
want a hyper growth you want hyper
growth for your channel figure out how
you can get one quality video out per
day not a live stream a regular video
every single day and we're gonna find
the time to do that Evan while you stop
focusing on celebrities and you stop
focusing on collaborations they stop
focusing platform marketing these things
work but they're not as effective as in
platform YouTube consistent content and
at least that's where the algorithm is
right now that may change in six months
but if you want to beat the people in
your industry you want to quickly
destroy them and be the number one
player in your niche the fastest way to
get there is to create consistent
content now other people have had
success without doing it maybe you have
a fantastic personality but yourself
maybe you were around before the
algorithm changes and so you've already
built up a huge base but if I always
start a new channel today or if I'm
trying to build a channel like I am
right now today the number one most
important factor that I'll be looking at
is creating consistent quality content
at least once per day here all your
efforts towards that and don't even
worry about the marketing or anything
else and a lot of the other best
practices that you'll see because this
is the one that works the best so I
think I've talked about creating
consistent content in model for the
videos in this series I'm probably going
to take a break from that topic and go
to something else next time the reason
why I'm hammering at home is because
you're not doing it because the people
who watched all four videos in the
series say yeah okay and they don't do
anything about it and then you still are
working on these other things that
aren't helping and my goal is to help
you get to whatever your subscriber goal
is I want some hyper growth for you and
so hopefully after this one after
beating you over the head to the message
repeatedly something's going to sink in
and and I would encourage you for the
next month if you're a youtuber for the
next month abandon all your other
projects abandon your collaborations for
a month abandon your outreach for a
month and just focus on getting one
video per day and see what happens to
your channel our listen to the questions
that came up from the last video I did
do some QA and hopefully provide some
extra value for you guys so last month I
went up against Grant Cardone showed my
channel against his given some advice
first comment comes from Grant thanks
having great job and great content let's
do a podcast on this this is how you add
value folks watch what evan is doing
here
smart glad you enjoyed a grant and again
I'm a big fan of the channel I'm a fan
of what grants doing so happy that he's
helping entrepreneurs as well and if he
applied some of these strategies he'd be
crushing it even more on his YouTube
channel
next up funky monkey so when a nutshell
grant needs to up his YouTube game
garyvee style gotcha no that's not the
advice you cannot have massive success
just by copying somebody else you have
to find your own rhythm so Gary has done
it by doing the daily blog now grant may
have success doing its daily blog
I may have success doing a daily blog
but not everybody is sincerely built for
that no everybody wants to do that if
you just try to copy
Gary's model of doing a daily vlog and
doing exactly everything he's doing
you're not going to get the same results
you're going to get much worse results
because Gary's doing him the advice is
not the copy Gary the advice is to
create more consistent content so Gary
had massive traction when he went to 2
videos a day so grant should go to 2
videos a day 2 videos of high quality
content every day whether that's a vlog
1 less it said show whether that's him
walking on the street and ranting about
something like he does that way better
than Gary does like Grant natural with
the phone freaking out about something
is awesome he should do more of that and
so it's not I don't want to encourage
any of you to try to be like me or Gary
or grains or whoever but you can use
some of the strategies so find the two
videos a day that you can work out for
yourself by swinging so he didn't some
success marks
based D makes a video how to get a
minute subscribers doesn't have a
million subscribers based DS the journey
bro
it's a journey pay attention to the
journey I've said that in every video
and I'm at 775 it's pretty close if you
can't learn but somebody who's had that
success compared to what do you add
beasty let's see base D has how many
subscribers a grand total of nine
congratulations you can learn something
from the people who've come before you
next up is WP with Tom love this episode
thank you Tom I'm considering making a
new channel in a different niche these
videos will take a while to make and
would be difficult to upload daily most
people in this niche I want to pursue
upload twice a month do you think it'd
be better to create a bunch of higher
quality videos prior to even uploading
the first video and then scheduled them
out more frequently or would be better
to just focus on creating three videos
per month to do more than a competition
the difference between two videos a
month and three videos a month is not
great I would be looking at how do I
make two videos a week and a lot of
times it just means you need to be
creative so if your competition is doing
two videos a month and you're doing two
a week you're going to start to win so
some creative ideas I don't know what
the nisha is that you're getting into
but can you have a Q&A session once a
week where you're answering questions
around that topic can you do some recaps
or mix-ups of different episodes that
you've done before around certain topics
so if you've answered the same question
maybe in different ways five different
times can you mash up different answers
kind of like what I did with the top ten
right mash up different answers can you
have a customer come on and ask you a
question can you tell a customer story
on the channel do you get upset and want
to rant about something is there some
high quality production that you want to
do twice a month but you're going to up
to once a week instead and so thinking
creatively in your industry about how
you can take that topic that you have in
your head and stop being restricted by
well people in our industry only do it
twice a month or it's difficult because
it's high quality content yeah this is
it's difficult it's an easy strategy but
it's not doesn't mean it's easy actually
cute right it's
I understand but it's not easy to go up
and do its work what I'm saying is take
the work away from these other things
where you're spending time on and focus
on this because it's a single most
effective marketing strategy that you
have right now on YouTube to go
subscribe trace next up is Benny
I love grant but he tends to spam a lot
with videos like the cardones own Genie
show young hustlers in the real estate
show he puts a one-minute previews but
the downside as potential viewers are
put off so Benny I don't know that I
would call it spam I think it's it's
what a lot of people think to do it's
what comes from TV and comes from movies
right there's a movie that comes out and
there's a trailer that comes up in
advance to promote it it just doesn't
play well with the YouTube algorithm
unless there's another purpose which
I've talked a ton of times about as well
but not in this video it's okay to put
out a video that will hurt your
subscribers that will hurt your numbers
that will hurt your YouTube growth if it
gives you some other strategic reason
right if grants putting out a new book
or grants putting out a new conference
or some event or some product that he's
trying to sell make a video about it
that's okay you're going to lose
subscriber growth but you have your
YouTube channel for a reason
right the reason is to help your
business grow so if there's something
you can do on your channel to help your
business grow that means you take a
short term hit on your channel for one
video it makes sense if you're just
promoting another video on the channel
and it's pulling everything down then a
probably doesn't make the most sense so
it's okay to have series that lose as
long as you understand that you're
losing subscribers because of that
series if you don't have the awareness
that it's happening you can't make the
right decisions
next up mental Kevlar just subscribe
this is pretty excellent love your top
tens also I appreciate that mental
Kevlar question part of this I feel too
soon for a brand-new baby level one
channel like mine do you think I should
wait a year before I begin to evaluate
my channels I sort of feel like I should
hit 10,000 subscribers for actually
start the value performance what are the
immediate action steps for me to take
like mine example I'm tempted to jump up
to one upload a day based on your
valuation that YouTube algorithm so it's
never too it's never too early to start
to evaluate your
I would just say at the beginning stages
you don't know how to make great content
just like the begin of anything you know
you know what looks good but you know
the ability to go in create it yet
because you need to develop the skills
you have to put in the repetition like
anything else right you want to learn
any kind of new skill dancing or French
or marketing or whatever it is you have
to put in the work to get better and so
alex is a quantity leads to the quality
and I would say if I was in your
position I would try as hard as I could
to move to one a day immediately one
because yes it does help that YouTube
algorithm and you're going to start
getting more traction with your videos
as long as they're not crap but two you
need to get better right so every time
you put out a new video you're going to
develop your skills you're going to
improve you're going to get better every
video will have higher quality and
higher quality higher quality and the
more you keep producing higher quality
videos the more subscribers and
attention YouTube is going to give you
and so I would go right to once a day if
you can find the time to make that
happen I think it's your best marketing
strategy but it's also your best product
content strategy because you're learning
how to make better videos in that
process I've made 5,000 videos on my
channel right a thousand of them haven't
gone live yet I have put videos and
practice videos and haven't gone live a
thousand of them more than most people
every create in their entire Channel and
so the quantity leads to the quality get
going one a day right now Ramon Klump
personally like this video a lot more
than the previous one you did with Gary
especially because you actually go in
and analyze the chainmail video by video
love to see where you believe other
channels are growing and why glad you
feel that Ramon this whole thing is a is
a exercise it's something that I wanted
to do for myself to understand and break
down these other YouTube channels and
also to give back to help you guys if
you have a important message in a
channel you're trying to build hopefully
by looking at that it gives you
knowledge to make your channel better so
I'll try to share some stats today as
well and I'll keep that in mind for
future videos regular slasher thanks
Evan I've just started my channel and I
want a boost subscription while making
content working with whatever I have
right now any advice Thanks
just start get started if you're
starting then just start use the gear
that you have used the knowledge you
have the tools you have the skills you
have and just start be consistent get
better every day do something else for
the channel start start start a lot of
people have this idea that has to be
perfect it has to be amazing it has to
be great and then you never do anything
I need the right gear and I need a
camera person I need the right light in
there what microphone to use and all of
this all of this stuff that matters a
little bit but doesn't really matter
what matters is you actually doing stuff
because you spend so much time creating
the perfect plan that then it never
happened because you don't have the
resources to go and make that happen
so you're just planing your head of all
these different ideas and nothing
actually comes out what's important is
the output so just start make your video
today and then make better one tomorrow
and a better one the next day keep that
trend going just in part plays sub to me
and comment when you're done then I'll
sub back so this is an interesting
strategy right you see a lot of the sub
to me and I'll sub back and I picked
this one out on purpose so one I applaud
that it's in platform right you're going
to have more success doing this and you
will try to promote on Twitter or
Facebook or Instagram or somewhere else
but it's not as good Tristan Park plays
I was just making good consistent
content stop wasting your time leaving
these comments on people's channels and
go out and make better content
consistently that's it
next up succumb hang about what I said
okay thanks so much my comment I switch
to one video day and the video was a
live stream I did it for a month and I
didn't gain any subs live stream is a
different algorithm I'm not a huge I'm
not huge into live streaming right now I
see it honestly much more as a way to
build connection with your audience so
that when you go live on the phone or on
your desktop people ask you questions
and there's a way to connect and answer
them one on one instead of just this
format here right when somebody is live
- it kind of keeps them engaged and you
want to see what happens next
but if so here's average of live streams
you make a live stream YouTube promotes
it more heavily than a regular video
while you are live
so people who are watching your other
videos it can be promoted to them I'm a
sidebar with the other videos it'll say
live now and your homepage of your
channel will say live now so they give
you a lot more promotional boost when
you are live the challenge is once a
video has finished it's not live anymore
you can save it and it can it can live
on as a regular video doesn't disappear
but from the algorithms perspective it
almost disappears it is very rare that
live streams continue to get consistent
views after the live stream is finished
and so that's why I don't do a lot of
live stream as part of my content
strategy I like it just to communicate
with you guys I liked it as a variety
I'll do one a week typically on Thursday
and so from that for you guys that may
be a lot but for me it's nothing right
I'm doing three videos a day so if we do
21 videos in a week only one of them is
a live stream that shows you what my
stance on live stream is right now just
in terms of gaining subscribers I had to
create a second channel for my live
streaming stuff because the live streams
were hurting my main channel and so if
you have a bad live stream it pulls down
the rest of your channel which sucks and
so I didn't want to do that so I took
them off and went to a different Channel
with them and so we'll do one main big
one per week I hope that changes because
I love live and I hope that the
algorithm changes in that respect I'm
sure more things are coming but as of
right now one video a day that is not a
live stream that's what you want
to be able to quickly grow your channel
next up Anthony progress great video
brother appreciate it Anthony I think
Grant Cardone garyvee Tai Lopez they
have so many channels that they aren't
just focused on YouTube 100% and I think
it's smart to have a business outside of
just YouTube because at some point
YouTube is going to go away and so you
need to be able to transition to
something else that being said the point
of this series is to show how you can
gain subscribers and some extra ideas
and tips and strategies to help you
quickly get more subscribers for your
YouTube channel and again if you have
some big strategic reason that's going
to help you further on your your
business goals or your personal goals
that sometimes
to hit on your YouTube account that's
fine do it just make sure that you know
the reason why every time I've said it
it's the same reason it's the same thing
it's okay to strategically hurt your
channel but be strategic about it where
most of the people who I'm profiling
most of the examples that I've shown
they don't have a reason for these clips
that are heard in their channel they
think it's helping them and they're not
it's why they're not winning as hard as
it could on YouTube Nextup Blonde Swift
video loves it all but at the 35 minute
mark you said about when just starting
out to just make videos has got to be
the most obvious and most overlooked
advice on how about how to channels keep
up the good work as newbies need to be
told the obvious I'm glad a house lawn
and hopefully there's some more obvious
tips that are giving you in this video
to help you on your journey
next up get back us a free computer
training make a video and how much money
you make on YouTube
I might make you money on YouTube I've
done a couple videos on that the point
of this series how to get 2 million
subscribers what I do after hit a
million I don't know I'm going to he'll
continue this series if you guys are
still find it valuable I might otherwise
I might switch to different topics or
just kill the series I don't know we
have a goal let's get there first and
then we'll see what happens to helpful
guys Evan how are you seeing his stats
what plugin are you using
so I'm not using a plug-in there's an
option on YouTube to show or hide your
stats stats are by default shown and you
have to turn them off and so a lot of
people have been profiling they just
don't care they keep their stats public
so let me share my screen and I'll show
you guys what I'm talking about so I'm
on YouTube here if I look at any video
let's look at Vox and see what they have
you know what I'm on the new template I
don't know if you guys are in the new
beta or not I don't know how to tell on
this there's some button somewhere here
that shows stats and if they haven't
turned it off you can see the stats and
if they have then you can't see the
stats so here all we can see is views
and thumbs up thumbs down let's see is
an option here now let's go to a
different channel just to see after
school yeah
not seeing the option here anymore it
may be a bug on the new template on the
new don't update to the new YouTube if
you want to be able to see people sad
I'm sure it's in here somewhere or
they're going to add it back in at some
point but basically if if they have not
opted out of sharing the data then
you're allowed to see it and it'll show
you everything that I've shown you guys
I'm not using any special plugins just
straight from YouTube tools next up
Raquel Evan professor Ned I didn't
subscribe to a few people when they
started uploading every day he's almost
ten million subscribers - I do
understand that and I think about it for
myself lose one or two but gaining three
or more so I think that was in reference
to somebody I guess professor Natan or
that Colin is around
he was unsubscribing to people who were
posting more than one video a day or
more than one video a week just because
it's started clogging up his his inbox
and I agree you know from my consumption
patterns the pizza channels that I
subscribe to if they're doing more than
a video a day and it's not really high
quality stuff I'm going to unsubscribe
from their channel but it's not the
typical behavior so you either go with
your behavior or you go with what the
market wants and in that scenario you
know I'm making stuff you know I would
watch all my videos I maybe that's the
difference like I like the videos of PB
does that I put up I watch them I would
watch them if I wasn't making them but
there been other channels that I have
unsubscribed from or don't pay attention
to all the videos like Gary's stuff I
don't really get off on the daily block
right it's not really for me I like his
I like the practitioner stuff I like the
answering the questions that's that's
the stuff that I like the most the daily
vlog stuff I don't I don't need that but
most people like that he's growing
because of that so keep doing it and
just because your behavior doesn't match
up it doesn't mean that it's still not
the right decision to do and so just
because I don't subscribe to many
channels that are making one video a day
or plus it doesn't mean that I shouldn't
be doing it the answer is just a test
instead of just thinking about things
and just writing something on
by default and saying this doesn't work
try it it's worked for me it's worked
for Gary it's working now for grant as
he's up in his content it's work
repeatedly consistently over and over
and over and over again and just because
you don't follow that same kind of
behavior doesn't mean you shouldn't give
it a shot so for the next month try it
and see what happens probably going to
grow your channel they can come back and
tell us about your progress next up we
are if 300k to go thanks for your if
it's now 225 K to go I'll keep updating
you guys on the progress next up EDD
heavens video is highly enjoyable one
question does a YouTube algorithm
strategy work outside of YouTube would
have work in the business world that's
an interesting question I think I think
whenever you are dealing with technology
of some sort so you know before I did
YouTube I was doing my website I didn't
do a lot of the other stuff I did
Twitter and Facebook and other things
but the more you can hack the algorithm
and know what is expected and match that
then you'll have success so my website I
was creating content myself and I
realized YouTube or not YouTube Google
wants lots of content they want lots of
high-quality content right and so like a
K from this to work I need to get other
people involved right I can't do all the
writing myself and so I got 8,000 people
to write for the website and then I
started getting bigger names recognized
people at that time Google didn't care
about duplicate content and so it take
the same content that people had on
their website so give me everything you
wrote them on your website that's ok
give it to me I'll put on my site and
I'll rank it I'll rank for it I'll give
you some promotion exposure right like
we're taking content that that they made
they're giving it to us like people are
giving us their content and saying thank
you at the same time because they're
getting way more exposure and promotion
then Google cared about duplicate
content so you have to cut out those
articles now you need unique original
articles and so in the technology world
as always for any of these platforms
Oh enough there there's always an
algorithm and the more you understand it
and the more you can break it down the
more success you'll have even if you
have less talent right where the talent
will always have a place and will always
win but if you don't understand the
algorithm you're going to have a hard
time it's like a race car and a race car
driver if you are a great race car
driver you can have success in any car
right it's your car if you if you have a
amazing car and you suck as a driver you
can still have some success but the best
is if you can combine the boat right and
so that's what that's what I believe if
you're looking at kind of human dynamics
and in the business world outside of
other you know networks or technology
it's just understanding how people work
it's just understanding patterns so if
you're looking at negotiation if you're
looking at sales it's attacking that
algorithm you know sales is about
listening sales is about solving
problems sales is about standing or
something and the more interactions you
have the more you start figuring things
out the great thing about that in human
in the in the human world is it changes
a lot less you know a lot of the sales
strategies that work now are still going
to work in ten years YouTube strategies
YouTube may not be around in ten years
and so understanding human dynamics
leadership you know leadership doesn't
change that off and a lot of that the
key parts about leadership are still
going to be the same relevant parts in
10 20 50 years as they are today where
again YouTube won't be around in 50
years and so I think the strategy can
still apply but it changes a lot less
compared to something like this and so
that's an opportunity it's an
opportunity because if you are in
leadership as an example it takes a lot
of experience and time and practice to
get to be great at it and so the people
who are ahead of you will be hard to
this place because they have a lot more
experience in practicing you where if
you look at YouTube every time there's
an algorithm update you've got all the
people who who are the older generation
on you
which isn't that old but the people had
success a year ago or two years ago or
three years ago they're all complaining
oh the algorithm updated YouTube let's
sue them you should change it back right
they're always complaining where that's
an opportunity like I seen updated our
rhythm yes this is awesome because I can
get even faster to where I want to go
and so it provides such an amazing
opportunity for you if you want to dig
game and try to understand the algorithm
it's why young people Millennials now
have so much opportunity way more than
they used to because young people never
used to have any respect they never got
respect you're young what do you know
you don't know anything but now they do
how many how many people you know like
we talk about respecting your elders and
for a lot of the ideas and strategies
you need to if you're talking to a
seven-year-old on leadership and they
spent their entire life leading
organizations you're going to respect
that person you're probably not going to
respect their opinion on Twitter or the
next YouTube algorithm update so for the
first time the older generation is
looking to the younger generation as
thought leaders as having expertise that
they don't have and so it's an
opportunity to win and so I think it
just depends if you if you want to play
that game and you're on top of all the
changes you can have disproportionate
success you can grow way faster than the
people around you who are complaining
about updates and changes because you're
diving in you're quickly understanding
how it works is the point of the series
I just said in this video don't worry
about collaboration don't worry about
celebrity endorsements don't worry about
off platform promotion that may all
change in three months that may be
totally relevant irrelevant or maybe
totally wrong in three months when
YouTube updates our algorithm or six
months or a year or three years but
right now it works focusing on one
quality video per day plus works you
will crush the people around you if you
start doing it mixed-up board question
you mentioned that if a video you
publish doesn't garner good watch time
or sub growth the YouTube algorithm will
it your next published video if you
publish videos to a different series and
then have very performance watch time
and sub growth does that mean you need a
different you need a strategy for what
to publish next and the sequence of what
you publish for example is a good to
experiment with a new series after great
performing channel video versus a poor
performing class video yes it's
something that I probably don't even do
enough of a good time a good job
tracking but if you have a really good
video and then you come out the next day
or the next upload with another really
good video those start to bounce off
each other and start to really help your
channel grow or if you have a good video
that then leads to a bad video that bad
videos start to pull down your channel
and so what I would try to do is
sequence them out a little bit more and
have a few test series so what I do is
an example like the top 10 series
started off as a test it did really well
we do that five times a week so
consistently we have five days out of
the week that we're uploading a new top
ten if I'm unsure about a new series
I'll usually test it on rotation once a
month so I have one spot as a flex spot
right now I think it's on the weekends
and once a week up one we could do this
and when we could do this somewhere we
could do this and what we could do this
so have four different ideas that we're
testing so one we did recently was
around books top 5 books around
marketing top 5 books for entrepreneurs
we also did ones about how billionaires
think
the billionaire sink one did really well
so that may now become a twice a month
series or maybe a once a week series or
maybe multiple times per week series
right and then the ones that don't do
well slowly fall off and so I think if
you can plan the testing in so that
you're 80% of your content is amazing
and great and you know is going to be
high performers because that strategy
has worked for you and the 20% is going
to be the experimental testing thing
where everything is just test trial mode
then you're going to have a hard time
getting that bounce effect happening
more if you have a good video and the
next one is really good like once you
have a really solid video what happened
the next 24 hours is really important
they're going to really give some credit
to that next video that you put up and
if it sucks
then it's you're missing out on a lot of
potential impact for your channel so if
you have a test idea that you're not
sure how it's going to do I would not
put it back to back with a video that is
stomping and doing really well all right
guys the game ended there there's a lot
more comments and questions but I have
to go pick up my son from camp it's
summertime and we're going to spend some
time together so thank you for watching
I'd love to know what you think of this
video and let me know what questions you
have because I'm going to answer them in
next month's edition whenever I decide
to put that again let's see what 775
what I think be in the hundreds by the
next one so I'm excited thank you guys
for joining me in the journey thank you
for the questions and the push and the
challenges and hopefully you use this
guy's like uses information to grow your
channel please otherwise I'm wasting my
time like at least some of you only some
of you take this and do something with
it to help grow your channels that's it
have a great rest of the day I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love cc